The leak reveals that House of the Dragon
will feature one of the most legendary brother
vs brother duel in Westeros history when twin
brothers who deeply loved each other also
fought each other because one of them sided
with Aegon and the other with Rhaenyra. A
leaked audition tape was recently posted and
(shortly after deleted) featuring two twin
actors reading the parts of legendary Cargyll
brothers, Arryk and Erryk. In this leaked
audition tape, actors who are identical twins
read a scene in which their characters Arryk
and Erryk discuss the rights of Prince Aegon,
soon to become King Aegon. Their dialogue
and physical gestures suggest that they are
guarding the prince while he visits a brothel,
something for which Aegon was very known.
Erryk is disturbed by Prince Aegon's behavior
and wonders aloud what sort of King for Westeros
Aegon will be if this is how he acts as a
Prince while Arryk insists that all men are
equally bad and that they should accept him
for what he is. Arryk says that the Hand of
the King, Ser Otto Hightower who is also Aegon's
grandfather, will keep him in check,
but Erryk still doesn't like the idea of Aegon
ruling Westeros. Anyways, that's the leaked
audition tape that spoiled a huge plot in
House of the Dragon. So who are these Arryk
and Erryk brothers? They are twin brothers
and both are members of the Kingsguard under
King Viserys, but they fought on opposite
sides of the Dance of the Dragons and ended
their lives with a legendary duel which inspired
many songs in Westeros. In this leak, Erryk
doubts that Prince Aegon will make a good
King, foreshadowing his allegiance to Rhaenyra
over Aegon, while Arryk is determined to stand
by the prince, regardless of his faults because
he thinks he is the rightful heir. Ser Arryk
and Ser Erryk Cargyll are knights from House
Cargyll. They are members of the Kingsguard
during the reign of King Viserys I Targaryen.
But when the king dies and his son and daughter
each declare themselves the rightful rulers
of Westeros, the Cargyll brothers are divided
for the first time. Arryk ends up siding with
Aegon Targaryen and Erryk with Rhaenyra Targaryen.
According to Septon Eustace, Arryk found Prince
Daemon and Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen in
bed together, a few months after the tourney
to celebrate King Viserys's and Queen Alicent's
fifth anniversary in 111 AC, which is why
he thinks Princess Rhaenyra is not much better
than Aegon. Meanwhile, in 120 AC King Viserys
I Targaryen made Erryk the sworn shield of
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, replacing Ser
Harwin Strong. After the death of Viserys,
Erryk followed Ser Steffon Darklyn and Ser
Lorent Marbrand in siding with the blacks
and joined the Queensguard of Rhaenyra. His
brother Arryk, however, supported Rhaenyra's
rival, King Aegon II Targaryen and the greens.
After the coronation of Aegon in the Dragonpit,
Arryk led the king into the throne room of
the Red Keep. Rhaenyra's coronation occured
shortly after on Dragonstone as Prince Daemon
placed the Old King's crown on the head of
his wife, proclaiming her Rhaenyra of House
Targaryen, First of Her Name, Queen of the
Andals, the Rhoynar, and the First Men. When
word of Rhaenyra's coronation reached the
Red Keep the next day, Aegon was furious.
Cooler heads on the green council wished to
parley. So Grand Maester Orwycle was dispatched
across Blackwater Bay under a peace banner,
leading a retinue that included Ser Arryk
Cargyll of the Kingsguard, in something that
ended up being an unsuccessful attempt to
reconcile the rival Targaryens. The terms
offered by the king were generous. If Queen
Rhaenyra would acknowledge him as king, Aegon
would confirm her in possession of Dragonstone
and allow the island and castle to pass to
her son upon her death. Pardons would be granted
to all lords and knights, including Erryk,
who had conspired against him. Rhaenyra heard
these terms in silence, Erryk by her side
as well as most of the blacks, then asked
Grand Maester Orwyle (who presented her these
terms on Aegon's behalf) if he remembers her
father King Viserys who named her as his heir
and successor, not Aegon. Grand Maester replied
that he remembers that the King named her
his heir.
Rhaenyra nodded and said "with your own tongue
you admit I am your lawful queen.
Why then do you serve my half-brother Aegon,
the pretender?" Orwyle gave a long reply citing
the Andal Law and the Great Council of 101.
The answer did not satisfy Rhaenyra.
"A Grand Maester should know the law and serve
it" she told him. "You are not Grand Maester,
and you only bring shame and dishonor to that
chain you wear". As Orwyle protested, Ser
Erryk stripped his chain of office from his
neck and forced him to his knees while the
princess bestowed the chain upon her own Measter.
As she sent Orwyle and Ser Arryk back to King's
Landing, Rhaenyra said "Tell my half-brother
that I will have my throne, or I will have
his head." Many years after the Targaryen
civil war was done, the singer Luceon of Tarth
would compose a sad ballad called "Farewell,
My Brother" that is still sung to this day.
The song tells a story of the last meeting
between Ser Arryk and his twin Ser Erryk Cargyll,
as Orwyle's party was boarding the ship that
would carry them back to King's Landing. Ser
Arryk had sworn his sword to Aegon, Ser Erryk
to Rhaenyra. In that song, each brother tries
to persuade the other to change sides. Upon
realization that each failed, they exchange
declarations of love and go their separate
ways, knowing that when they meet again, they
will meet as enemies. Upon a few following
events, Arryk will go on a mission to Dragonstone
where he will meet and fight his brother Erryk
to death. It all started when Rhaenyra's second
son, Lucerys, flew on his dragon to Storm's
End to gain an alliance with House Baratheon,
but Aegon II's brother Aemond flew to Storm's
End at the same time to pursue the same goal,
riding the older dragon Vhagar. Storm's End
subsequently supported Aegon II. Aemond, riding
Vhagar, killed Luke over Shipbreaker Bay as
he attempted to leave after failing to gain
Lord Baratheon's allegiance.
This then led to Rhaenyra and Daemon taking
revenge against Aegon and sending Blood and
Cheese, nicknames of two men who sneaked into
the Red Keep and killed his son. A son for
a son. This then led to King Aegon's desire
to avenge the killing of his heir by Blood
and Cheese by means of an attack on Dragonstone,
descending on the island citadel on dragonback
to seize or slay Rhaenyra and her sons.
It took all of the green council to change
his strategy. Ser Criston Cole urged a different
course.
"Rhaenyra had made use of stealth and tracheary
to kill his son", Cole said to Aegon, "so
let's do the same" he continued. "We will
pay the princess back in her own bloody coin"
he told the king.
The instrument the Lord Commander of the Kingsguard
chose for the king's vengeance was his Sworn
Brother, Ser Arryk Cargyll. Many fishermen
arrive daily on Dragonstone so it would be
a simple thing to deliver Arryk to the island.
From there he would make his own way to the
queen, pretending to be Ser Erryk for Arryk
and Erryk were twins, identical in all respects;
not even their fellow members of the Kingsguard
could tell the two apart. Ser Arryk should
be able to move freely at Dragonstone, Ser
Criston suggested as any guards to encounter
him would surely mistake him for his brother.
After King Aegon gave this mission a green
light, Lord Commander of Aegon's Kingsguard
and therefore Arryk's Lord Commander as well,
Ser Criston, ordered Arryk to infiltrate Dragonstone,
although it's disputed whether his mission
was to kill Rhaenyra or her children or even
both. Ser Arryk did not undertake his mission
happily. He thought this to be dishonorable
for a knight of the Kingsguard. Septon Eustace
says that Arryk visited the Red Keep's sept
on the night he was to sail for Dragonsone,
to pray for forgiveness to Mother Above. Yet
as Kingsguard, sworn to obey king and commander,
he had no choice in honor, but to do as commanded
or die trying. Ser Arryk came ashore Dragonstone,
donned his armor and white cloak, and had
no trouble gaining entrance to the castle
in disguise of his twin brother. Deep in the
hearth of Dragonstone, as he was making his
way to the royal apartments where Rhaenyra
and her sons were, the gods brought Arryk
face-to-face with his brother Ser Erryk who
knew at once what his brother's presence meant.
Ser Erryk said "I love you brother" as he
drew his blade, and Ser Arryk replied "I love
you too, brother" as he drew his own. The
twins battled for the best part of an hour.
The clash of steel on steel woke half of the
Queen Rhaenyra's court, but all they could
do was stand by helplessly and watch, for
no man could tell which brother was which.
In the end, Ser Arryk and Ser Erryk dealt
each other mortal wounds, and died in one
another's arms with tears upon their cheeks.
That's the story of the legendary Cargyll
brothers. When I say Targaryen fought Targaryen,
dragon fought dragon, and brother fought brother
during the Targaryen civil war, I mean it
and you will see it for yourself in 2022 on
HBO. Thank you so much for watching! If you
enjoyed this video please give it a big thumbs
up and I hope to see you in the next one.